もう決めたうん私キーマカレーとプレイ
なーにする同元は今日のセット美味しそう
だな刺バボをチキンティカに変更できるの
かな聞いてみたらそうだなあすいません
はい行きますあえっとキーマカレと
プレインナンを1枚それから今日のセット
なんですけどこのシシケバブをチキン
ティカに変更できますかはいできますだっ
てんだって
あじゃあチキンティに変更してください
かしこまりましたナンは何にしますかあ
そうだナはまだ決めてなかったえっと
チーズナンとこのモライナンはどっちがお
すめですかそうですね両方美味しいんです
けどチーズナンはちょっと重いので私は
モグライナの方が好きですだってうんだっ
てようん今聞いたからん店員さんの発言が
聞こえていないと思ったうんじゃなんで
だってって言ったんなんでってだから
さっきからだってって言ってるけどその
発言って何の役割をしてるいや店員さんが
そうだって言ってるだけうんでも店員さん
がそうだってことはもう知ってるなんで
かって店員さんがそれを俺に言ったから
知らないと思って言ってるわけじゃないよ
じゃあなんで言う第3者が知ってるのは
知ってるけどこの人が今こう言いましたと
発言する理由は何考えすぎ会話の流れよ
こうだけどどうするそういうニュアンス
同じことだよえだから第3者に急にどう
するって言われなくても行動するから会話
を促してるだけまさにそれだは私が促さ
ないとこの人は行動しないだろうだってっ
て発言には新しい情報が入ってないから
そういう風にしか解釈できないいや違う
違うだからなんか他人の前で馬鹿にされ
てる感じがしてめっちゃ嫌だよ分かった
合槌だ合槌そうそうそうそう会話中に日本
ってうんうんうんとか言って相手に振る
じゃんうんそれと同じ続けていいよって
いう合図だけむしろ意味なんてないから
いやそうかもしれないけどなんかあんまり
好きな言い方じゃないからちょっとだけ
控えてもらっていいえもうめんどくさい
めんどくさいとは思うけどお願いだこれは
俺の気持ちだだってあんたは黙っ
て
til